I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello! Hi there, you guys.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起演过《办公室》，而且是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。女士们，我们是《办公室》。大家好！你们好啊，各位。
I'm so happy to be here today. I don't know, I'm just feeling real thankful. I'm in a good mood too. Oh man, well, buckle in everybody, you got two happy ladies this morning. We're talking about Ultimatum, which was season 7, episode 13. It was directed by Dave Rogers and it was written by Carrie Kemper. She is a new writer this season and she is the sister of Ellie Kemper. Those two gals were so fun on set together.
我今天很高兴能来到这里。我不知道，我就是觉得非常感激。我今天心情也很好。天哪，大家系好安全带吧，今天早上有两位开心的女士。我们要聊的是第7季第13集《最后通牒》。这一集由戴夫·罗杰斯执导，凯莉·肯珀编剧。她是本季的新编剧，也是艾莉·肯珀的妹妹。这两个姑娘在片场一起玩得可开心了。
You could just see their sisterhood and it was so cute. They send out a joint Christmas card every year with their kids on it and I can't wait to get it. It's so creative every year. One year it was our favorite. We voted, you know, which was our favorite card and it was theirs and I texted Ellie. Was it the computer one? Yes!
你能看出她们浓浓的姐妹情深，真是太可爱了。她们每年都会寄出一张印有各自孩子的联合圣诞贺卡，我迫不及待想收到它。每年都极有创意。有一年那是我们的最爱。你知道的，我们投票选出了我们最喜欢的卡片，就是她们的那张，我还给艾莉发了短信。是电脑那张吗？对！
It was great. Yeah. It was so great. I believe The Office was Carrie's first staffing job. I'm sorry, Carrie, if I'm getting that wrong, but I know that after The Office, she went on to work on Silicon Valley as a writer and producer and she most recently worked as a writer for the rehearsal, which Lee loves. I have not watched it yet.
太棒了。是啊。真的很棒。我相信《办公室》是凯莉的第一份有员工编制的工作。对不起，凯莉，如果我记错了的话，但我知道在《办公室》之后，她去担任了《硅谷》的编剧和制片人，最近她还担任了莉的最爱《排练》的编剧。我还没看呢。
I haven't seen it either. Getting rave reviews. Okay. Would you like a summary? So much. All right. After much anticipation, Michael loses his cool when he learns that Holly did not enforce her Ultimatum deadline and that she is still dating AJ.
我也没看。反响极其热烈。好的。想要个剧情简介吗？非常想。好的。在万众期待之下，迈克尔得知霍莉并没有严格执行她的最后通牒期限，而且她依然在和AJ交往，这让他瞬间破防。
Pam tries unsuccessfully to help everyone make and keep New Year's resolutions, which Michael turns into an opportunity to shame his employees. Meanwhile, Daryl gets Dwight and Andy to drive him to the bookstore under the guise of picking up women, but really he just wants some new books. Yeah. Let's see. Should I guess a fast fact? I know you're about to hit me with them, but can I guess one?
帕姆试图帮助每个人制定并坚持新年决心，但没有成功，迈克尔却把这变成了一个羞辱员工的机会。与此同时，达里尔带着德怀特和安迪开车送他去书店，借口是去钓凯子，但实际上他只是想买几本新书。好吧。让我想想。我能猜一个趣味冷知识吗？我知道你正准备抛出它们，但我能猜一个吗？
Yes. I'm going to guess a location breakdown. Ding, ding, ding. That's all I got. Okay. Well, I have two location breakdowns. So really you got two out of the three fast facts, but fast fact number one is called no Jim. We had a fan question from CRT in Denmark and many others who said...
可以。我要猜一个取景地盘点。答对了，答对了，答对了。我就知道这些。好吧。我有两个取景地盘点。所以实际上你猜中了三个趣味冷知识中的两个，但趣味冷知识一叫做“没有吉姆”。我们收到了来自丹麦的CRT以及许多其他人的粉丝提问，他们说……
Denmark. Yeah. Denmark. Coming in from Denmark. Cool. I know. Here's what everyone said. We noticed that Jim is gone from this episode.
丹麦。对。丹麦。来自丹麦的提问。酷。我知道。大家是这么说的。我们注意到吉姆在这集中消失了。
Where is Jim? Love from Denmark. Hmm. Yes, it's true. Jim appears in the cold open of this episode, but he's not in the rest of the episode. Here's why. John Krasinski was in Alaska filming the movie Big Miracle. That Ken Kwaap is directed.
吉姆去哪儿了？来自丹麦的爱。嗯。是的，没错。吉姆出现在这集的冷开场中，但接下来的部分他都不在。原因如下。约翰·卡拉辛斯基当时在阿拉斯加拍摄电影《奇迹的诞生》。由肯·夸皮执导。
Yes. Randy Cordray said that a request was made for John to be able to miss this week of work in order to do the movie. That request was approved by both Paul and Greg. Now in our biz, if you miss a week of work for your reasons, you miss a paycheck. Yeah. But if they write a story to support you being gone, they have to pay you. So the producers arranged it so that he could pre-record the cold open before he left.
是的。兰迪·科德雷说，有人提出请求，希望约翰能够请假一周去拍这部电影。这个请求得到了保罗和格雷格的批准。现在在我们的行业里，如果你因个人原因请假一周，你就拿不到这一周的薪水。是的。但如果他们专门写一段剧情来支持你离开，他们就必须付钱给你。所以制作人们做了安排，让他在离开前预先录好了冷开场。
So he appeared in the episode. But also within the episode, there was a story point that Jim had to be away all day on a sales call. I also found something in the candy bag alts. Oh, really? Yeah. I remember Michael goes to Pam and is like, Pam, will you talk to Holly? You know that scene?
所以他出现在了这一集中。但同时在这集里，剧情设定吉姆整天都要出去打销售电话。我还从废案的糖果袋里发现了一些东西。哦，真的吗？对。我记得迈克尔去找帕姆说，帕姆，你能不能去跟霍莉谈谈？你记得那个场景吗？
There were candy bag alts for that scene. And one of them, Michael says, well, if you won't do it, what about Jim? And Pam says, Jim is sick. Oh, yeah. Interesting. I remember shooting a scene where he called Pam on the phone. I totally shot my side of that scene and they were going to add his voice later, but it ended up getting deleted.
那个场景的糖果袋废案里有很多台词。其中一条是迈克尔说，好吧，如果你不去做，那吉姆呢？帕姆说，吉姆生病了。哦，对。有趣。我记得拍摄过一个他给帕姆打电话的场景。我完全拍完了我那部分的戏，他们本来打算稍后再加进他的声音，但最后还是被删掉了。
So yeah, no Jim in the main episode. That's right. John Krasinski got to make his movie. He also, they found a way for him to appear in this episode. There you have it. Do we have a location breakdown? We sure do. It's fast fact number two.
所以，是的，正片里没有吉姆。没错。约翰·卡拉辛斯基去拍他的电影了。而且，他们也找到了让他在这一集里露面的方法。事情就是这样。我们有取景地盘点吗？当然有。这是趣味冷知识之二。
We went on three locations for this episode. We were in a parking lot outside of a strip club. Oh, yeah. We went into a bookstore and then we went into a roller rink. I'll have you know, we shot all of those locations on one day, which meant there was a lot of relocation for the cast and crew. That's a lot of moving. It was.
我们这一集去了三个取景地。我们在脱衣舞俱乐部外面的停车场。哦，对。我们进了一家书店，然后我们去了一家轮滑场。我得告诉你们，我们把所有这些地方都在一天之内拍完了，这意味着演员和剧组人员有大量的转移工作。那得搬多少次家啊。确实。
I'm going to start with the bookstore. Okay. Here's your location breakdown. It was a boarder's books. It was located in Northridge, California. And according to its Facebook page, it was the first boarder's books located in the valley. Hmm.
我要从书店开始说。好的。这是你的取景地盘点。那是博德斯书店（Border's Books）。它位于加利福尼亚州诺斯里奇。根据它的脸书主页，它是山谷地区第一家博德斯书店。嗯。
Do you remember boarder's books? I do. Same. They were like a big, big bookstore. Yes. Very popular. I did a little deep dive on them. Here's what I found out.
你还记得博德斯书店吗？我记得。我也是。它们就像是一家超级大书店。是的。非常受欢迎。我稍微深入研究了一下它们。这是我发现的。
Okay. The very first store opened in Ann Arbor, Michigan and it was owned by two brothers and they specialized in used books. Love it. But eventually their company expanded. They started selling new releases and they were kind of the first bookstore to do what they called big box bookstores. They had this idea that they really leaned into that a bookstore could be a place that
好的。第一家店开在密歇根州的安娜堡，由两兄弟拥有，他们专门经营二手书。太棒了。但最终他们的公司扩张了。他们开始出售新书，而且他们可以说是第一家做他们所说的大卖场式书店的书店。他们有这样一个理念并坚定不移地执行，那就是书店可以是一个不仅仅是买书的地方。
was more than just buying books. It was like a place to hang out. It was a social hub. So they built cafes, they served breakfast, but they also sold music, DVDs, greeting cards. The boarder's books chain was very famous for their number of two-story locations. And in fact, the design of their stores was very meticulously curated. I found an article with the company's architect, Mark Lorty, who said, quote, some boarder's stores featured circular turret towers that would jut out of the corner of the facade
它就像是一个聚会场所。它是一个社交枢纽。所以他们建造了咖啡馆，提供早餐，他们还出售音乐、DVD、贺卡。博德斯书店连锁店以其大量的两层楼店面而闻名。事实上，他们店面的设计经过了非常一丝不苟的策划。我找到了一篇文章，里面引用了公司的建筑师马克·洛蒂（Mark Lorty）的话，他说，引述如下，“一些博德斯书店设有环形炮塔楼，从建筑外观的角落凸显出来，
physically embodying some of the idyllic romance and innocence of children's books. They really bought it through. Yeah. Like Pam wanted a tower. She could go to boarder's books and pretend it was her tower. I know. Her terrace. Well, boarder's books have since shut down.
实体化了童话书中那种田园诗般的浪漫与纯真。”他们真的把这个理念贯彻到底了。对。就像帕姆想要一座塔楼。她可以去博德斯书店，假装那是她的塔楼。我知道。她的露台。好吧，博德斯书店后来倒闭了。
In 2011, the company filed for bankruptcy, they think that the thing that led to their downfall was that in the early 2000s, the economy started moving away from brick and mortar businesses and more to web internet retail. And you could just get a book for cheaper on the internet. A lot of people still went to the stores, but they were kind of treating them just like de facto libraries. They would go and browse, and then they would go home and buy a book online. I don't want bookstores to go away, you guys.
2011年，该公司申请破产，他们认为导致其衰落的原因是，在21世纪初，经济开始从实体店业务转向网络互联网零售。你可以在网上更便宜地买到书。很多人仍然去实体店，但他们有点把实体店当成事实上的图书馆了。他们会去浏览，然后回家在网上买书。我可不希望书店消失，伙计们。
Can we all rally to keep bookstores and libraries out there in the world? Yes, I could not agree more. I mean, there is nothing more fun than visiting your local library or bookstore with your kiddos, especially when they're little. Oh, it's so fun. You go and you pick out a book together. Don't even get me started if there's story time. We need our bookstores and libraries.
我们能一起声援，把书店和图书馆保留在这个世界上吗？是的，我不能同意更多了。我的意思是，没有什么比带着你的小不点们去当地的图书馆或书店玩更有趣的了，尤其是当他们还小的时候。哦，太有趣了。你们一起去挑一本书。如果有故事时间的话，那就更别跟我提了。我们需要我们的书店和图书馆。
We do. Was that a soapbox? Did I have a soapbox about bookstores? Angela. That was, you had a moment. I had a box moment. I'm proud of you. Thank you.
我们确实需要。刚才那是发表慷慨陈词吗？我刚才就书店发表了一篇慷慨陈词吗？安吉拉。是的，你刚才很有情绪。我有了一个慷慨陈词的高光时刻。我为你骄傲。谢谢。
Well, the site of this former boarder's books that we used was part of the Northridge Fashion Center Mall. When it first closed, it was turned into a sports authority, but that closed too, and now it is part of Dave and Buster's. Oh, okay. And now, are you going to break down this skating rink? You know I am, Angela. I'm very excited.
好吧，我们使用的这个前博德斯书店的旧址是诺斯里奇时尚中心购物中心的一部分。它刚关门时，变成了一家运动权威（Sports Authority）商店，但那家店也关门了，现在它是Dave and Buster's餐厅的一部分。哦，好吧。那么，现在你要盘点这个滑冰场了吗？你知道我会的，安吉拉。我很兴奋。
Next fact number three, the roller rink where we shot this episode was called Skateland. I knew it. And it was in Northridge. I've been there. You love to roller skate. I love roller skating. You roller skate in your kitchen. You roller skate down your street.
下一个冷知识之三，我们拍摄这一集的轮滑场叫做Skateland。我就知道。它在诺斯里奇。我去过那里。你喜欢轮滑。我喜欢轮滑。你在你的厨房里轮滑。你在你的街道上轮滑。
There are three pairs of roller skates in like the little cubby by my front door. Yeah. And you've roller skated here for pleasure, not for work. Yes. Do you know the history of this skating rink because I've got it for you? I don't. I just know when you go into it, it feels very 70s. Okay.
我前门旁边的小隔间里有三双轮滑鞋。是的。而且你在这里轮滑是为了娱乐，不是为了工作。是的。你知道这个滑冰场的历史吗？因为我已经帮你查过了。我不知道。我只知道当你走进去的时候，感觉非常70年代。好吧。
Well, it was a family-owned and operated skating rink that was open for more than 60 years, but has recently closed. Yes. It closed down because of the pandemic. They couldn't come back. You couldn't be indoors. Mm-hmm. Yeah.
嗯，这是一个由家族拥有和经营的轮滑场，营业了60多年，但最近关门了。是的。它是因疫情而关门的。它们无法恢复营业。你不能在室内活动。嗯哼。是的。
The outdoor skating areas thrived, but the indoor ones took a hit. Others, David and Mike Fleming had been running it. David said his father always wanted to be in the roller skating business because that is how he met their mother. Aw. Yeah. They met roller skating when he was in the service in Chicago. That is adorable.
户外滑冰场生意兴隆，但室内滑冰场受到了打击。大卫和迈克·弗莱明兄弟一直在经营它。大卫说他父亲一直想从事轮滑生意，因为那是他遇到他们母亲的方式。哦。是的。当他在芝加哥服役时，他们通过轮滑相识了。这太可爱了。
It was a whole business built on romance. That is so sweet. David also said that his brother trained Olivia Newton-John for Xanadu at that rink. And that he trained James Kahn for the original rollerball film. Oh, my God, that's so cool. The brothers sold the space to Ken Craft, who is the CEO of Hope of the Valley Rescue Mission. I actually follow them on Instagram.
这是一个建立在浪漫之上的商业帝国。真是太甜蜜了。大卫还说，他的哥哥在那家滑冰场为奥莉维亚·纽顿-约翰出演《仙乐飘飘处处闻》进行过训练。而且他还为原版《滚球大战》电影训练过詹姆斯·卡恩。哦，天哪，太酷了。兄弟俩把这个场地卖给了肯·克拉夫特，他是“山谷希望救援使命”（Hope of the Valley Rescue Mission）的首席执行官。我其实在Instagram上关注了他们。
They do amazing work. They transform skate land into a 107-bed bridge homeless housing facility where people can stay before finding more permanent housing. All of the residents have access to mental health services, drug and alcohol recovery programs, life skill classes, and every resident gets a case manager. That is amazing. Yeah. I think about the dad who started the skating rink because based on his love for his wife,
他们做着了不起的工作。他们把Skateland改造成为一个拥有107个床位的无家可归者过渡住房设施，人们在找到更永久的住房之前可以留在这里。所有的居民都可以获得心理健康服务、戒毒和戒酒康复项目、生活技能课程，而且每个居民都会配备一个案头经理。太惊人了。是的。我想到了那个创办轮滑场的父亲，因为基于他对妻子的爱，
what a perfect way to then share that love and compassion if you're going to sell your company like this is the best. Isn't it amazing? Yeah. It's amazing now, and it's called the Trebek Center in honor of Alex Trebek because the Trebek family donated the first $500,000 to the project to help convert the space from roller rinked housing facility. Alex Trebek's widow, Jean Trebek, spoke at the opening of the center and said, quote,
然后把这份爱和同情心分享出去，这是多么完美的方式啊。如果你要卖掉你的公司，像这样就是最好的方式。是不是太惊人了？是的。现在太棒了，为了纪念亚历克斯·特雷贝克，它被命名为特雷贝克中心，因为特雷贝克家族向该项目捐赠了最初的50万美元，用于帮助将这个空间从轮滑场改造为住房设施。亚历克斯·特雷贝克的遗孀让·特雷贝克在该中心的开幕式上发言说，引述如下，
we all know homelessness is complicated. There is no single pathway to the streets. There is no single intervention that ends homelessness. It here is a single remedy, and it's called love. Supporting another is loving another, and the transformational power of support will surely be known at this site. That's so beautiful. It's just what you said.
我们都知道无家可归问题很复杂。通往街头的道路绝非只有一条。也没有单一的干预措施能彻底结束无家可归。这里有一种唯一的救赎，它被称为爱。支持他人就是爱他人，支持所具有的变革力量肯定会在这个地方展现出来。太美了。这正是你刚才所说的。
This property has always been rooted in love. Wow. I did not see that coming about skate land. And that finishes my fast facts. Well, should we go to break? Well, before we go to break, recently, if you remember, who would be the last episode, Santa Kins visited us. Oh, I remember Santa Kins.
这处房产一直以来都根植于爱。哇。我真没料到Skateland会有这样的结局。我的趣味冷知识到此结束。好吧，我们该去休息一下吗？嗯，在休息之前，最近，如果你还记得的话，谁会是上一集的人物，圣塔金斯（Santa Kins）来拜访过我们。哦，我记得圣塔金斯。
Brought us gifts out of the blue, and I don't know if you thought there would be no repercussions to that. You are wrong. So I got you guys something. It's in front of you. You mentioned wanting it one day, and that day is now. Santa Sam! Santa Sam!
莫名其妙地给我们带了礼物，我不知道你当时是不是觉得这不会产生任何后续影响。你错了。所以我给你们俩准备了东西。它就在你们面前。你曾经提到过有一天想要它，而那一天就是现在。山姆老人！山姆老人！
What did you get us? There's a little wrapped item on this desk, and it's heavy. It is heavy. Those are your brass stamps for your wax seals. Oh, my God! On the back of your handbook. Sam! Oh, my gosh!
你给我们带了什么？桌上有一个包装好的小物件，而且很沉。确实很沉。那是你们用于蜡封的黄铜印章。哦，天哪！在你的手册背面。山姆！哦，天哪！
Stop it! Yeah. Sam, this is so thoughtful. These have my actual initials on them. I know. So they're for your wax seals in the back of your scrolls. Oh, my gosh. I do have a request.
别这样！是的。山姆，这太贴心了。这些上面有我真正的首字母缩写。我知道。所以它们是用来盖在你的卷轴背面的蜡封上的。哦，天哪。我有一个请求。
Two things. One, I call dibs on first letter. Okay. And two, the letter cannot be a thank you for the stamp. Okay. It's simple how your day went written in the style of Angela's diary. All right. I'm going to write you a journal entry, Sam, that you are going to treasure.
两件事。第一，我先挑第一个字母。好吧。第二，信的内容不能是“谢谢你送的印章”。好吧。只需用安吉拉日记的风格，简单写写你的一天是怎么度过的。好吧。山姆，我要给你写一篇日记，你会把它当成宝贝的。
Oh, my God. That is so cool, Sam. I can't wait to wax stamp a letter. Stamp away for all your Game of Thrones style stamping channel. Thank you, Santa Sam. My pleasure. We are back and we're in the conference room because there is a meeting. It's night time.
哦，天哪。太酷了，山姆。我迫不及待地想用蜡封信了。尽情地盖章吧，为了你那权力的游戏风格的盖章频道。谢谢你，山姆老人。不用谢。我们回来了，我们在会议室里，因为有一个会议。现在是夜晚。
None of the regular Dunder Mifflin crew is there. But Dwight is there with the Knights of the Night. Yes. He explains that the Knights of the Night are volunteer crime patrollers. Yes, they wear red beanie hats, black shirts that say we are unarmed on the back and on the front. It says Knights of the Night. A few of them have little medals.
邓德米夫林的常规员工全都不在。但德怀特和“暗夜骑士团”在那里。是的。他解释说“暗夜骑士团”是志愿犯罪巡逻员。是的，他们戴着红色的无檐毛线帽，穿着黑衬衫，背面写着“我们未武装”，正面写着“暗夜骑士团”。其中几个人还有小勋章。
Oh, for, I guess, good work. Good work with their flashlights. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Jim Halpert is going to come into work. He can't find his blackberry. And Dwight is convinced that Jim is going to make fun of his group. Yeah.
哦，我想是为了表彰出色的工作。用手电筒做得好。嗯哼。嗯哼。吉姆·哈尔珀特来上班了。他找不到他的黑莓手机了。德怀特坚信吉姆会嘲笑他的团队。是的。
Jim has stumbled upon something he's quite smug, but he ultimately doesn't do anything. For once, although I'm sure he's filing it away for later use. We had a fan question from Celine B in Century, Florida. Is there any backstory for why the Knights of the Night t-shirts say we are unarmed on the back? And then other people wrote in and to comment that the Knights of the Night look quite a bit like Devo. Oh, yes.
吉姆偶然发现了这个，他显得十分自鸣得意，但他最终什么也没做。破天荒地，虽然我确信他把它记在心里准备以后再用。我们收到了来自佛罗里达州世纪市塞琳·B的粉丝提问：“暗夜骑士团”T恤背面写着“我们未武装”，这有什么背景故事吗？然后其他人写信评论说，“暗夜骑士团”看起来有点像迪沃（Devo）乐队。哦，是的。
I did a side by side. Oh, I love Devo. Remember Devo? Anyone out there? Whip it good. Oh, yeah. Try to detect it. It's not too late.
我做了一个对比。哦，我爱迪沃。还记得迪沃吗？外面有人吗？尽情扭摆吧。哦，是的。试着察觉它。现在还不晚。
Ma-na-na-na-na. Correct. That whip. Here you go. Yes. That is Knights of the Night, along with Devo. And a great screen grab of Edward Nielsen III from our crew. Yes.
玛娜娜娜娜。没错。那个扭摆。给你。是的。这就是暗夜骑士团，还有迪沃乐队。还有我们剧组的爱德华·尼尔森三世的一个精彩银幕截图。是的。
One minute, 17 seconds. He is one of the Knights. He's in the front row closest to the windows. It was so fun to see him there. I know. Well, the shirts and the red beanies were a script note. The script note did not say anything about Devo. It said simply, quote, a man in black walks by in a red beanie nods to Jim.
1分17秒。他是骑士之一。他在靠近窗户的第一排。看到他在那里真是太有趣了。我知道。嗯，那些衬衫和红色无檐帽是剧本上的笔记。剧本笔记里没有提迪沃乐队的事。它只是简单地写道，引述如下，“一个穿着黑衣服、戴着红色无檐帽的男人走过，向吉姆点了点头。
His shirt reads, Knights of the Night, and on the back we are unarmed. Jim looks to camera. In the conference room are Dwight and eight other men, including Nate, dressed the same. Dwight kind of alludes to this in his talking head. The Knights of the Night were a spin on the group The Guardian Angels, who wore red berets and white shirts with The Guardian Angels logo. They were founded in New York in 1979 as an unarmed volunteer crime prevention organization. So kind of like a neighborhood watch in a way.
他的衬衫上写着‘暗夜骑士团’，背面写着‘我们未武装’。”吉姆看着镜头。会议室里坐着德怀特和其他八个男人，包括奈特，都穿着一样的衣服。德怀特在对着镜头独白时有点暗示了这一点。“暗夜骑士团”是对“卫理天使”这个团体的戏仿，“卫理天使”戴着红色贝雷帽，穿着印有“卫理天使”标志的白衬衫。他们于1979年在纽约成立，是一个非武装的志愿犯罪预防组织。所以有点像某种社区巡逻队。
Yes, exactly. But with outfits. Yes, exactly. Okay. So that's it. I feel like mom detectives might call on Knights of the Night. Oh, for backup. Maybe.
是的，完全正确。但有制服。是的，完全正确。好吧。就这样。我觉得妈妈侦探可能会召唤“暗夜骑士团”。哦，为了增援。也许吧。
If we knew Dwight, we might. I recognized a familiar face. The leader of The Knights of the Night is Seamus McCarthy. I've known Seamus for years. We've done improv together. We've performed at IOS. He is hilarious. And one of my favorite things about his Instagram, which is I am Seamus McCarthy, is he takes
如果我们了解德怀特的话，我们可能会的。我认出了一张熟悉的面孔。“暗夜骑士团”的领袖是谢默斯·麦卡锡（Seamus McCarthy）。我认识谢默斯很多年了。我们一起演过即兴喜剧。我们在IOS演出过。他太滑稽了。关于他的Instagram账号（@iamseamusmc_arthy），我最喜欢的事情之一就是他会拍
photos of his coffee order and how people interpret Seamus. His name. Yes. And there's just a series of photos of different spellings. That's really funny to me. When the episode begins, we have a Michael talking head. It is January 3rd, 2011, a day that will live in famously. I looked up January 3rd, 2011.
他的咖啡订单照片，以及人们如何解读谢默斯。他的名字。是的。那里有一系列不同拼写方式的照片。这对我来说真的很好笑。当这一集开始时，我们看到了迈克尔的独白。那是2011年1月3日，一个注定要在臭名昭著中永存的日子。我查了一下2011年1月3日。
What'd you find out? I wanted to know if there was anything infamously about it. Okay. According to the internet, first thing you should know is it was a Monday. Okay. Here are the top five songs in the USA on January 3rd, 2011. Bruno Mars, Grenade, Katy Perry, Firework, Kesha, We Are Who We Are, Rihanna, What's My Name, and Pink, Raise Your Glass.
你查到了什么？我想知道那天是不是有什么臭名昭著的事。好吧。根据互联网的说法，首先你应该知道那天是星期一。好吧。以下是2011年1月3日美国排行榜前五名的歌曲：布鲁诺·马斯的《Grenade》，凯蒂·佩里的《Firework》，凯莎的《We Are Who We Are》，蕾哈娜的《What's My Name》，以及粉妈的《Raise Your Glass》。
Kickass, directed by Matthew Vaughn, was one of the most viewed movies. And I Remember Nothing by Nora Efron was one of the bestselling books. Okay. The only thing that Michael is worried about is whether or not Holly is engaged. And he's kind of freaking out. We're going to do that thing where we think we're doing a private talking head, but the camera's going to pull out to reveal that Erin is there and she's filming him because he's going to make both a sad video and a happy video where he's talking to himself.
由马修·沃恩执导的《海扁王》是观看人数最多的电影之一。诺拉·埃夫伦的《我恨我自己》是畅销书之一。好吧。迈克尔唯一担心的是霍莉是否订婚了。他有点抓狂。我们要上演那个桥段了：我们以为自己在做私人独白，但镜头拉开，露出了艾伦，她正在拍摄他，因为他要录制一段悲伤的视频和一段快乐的视频，在视频里他自言自语。
Yes. Because the only person that can talk Michael down is Michael. Yeah. If you notice the video camcorder that Erin is using, it's a little bit of old tech. And I can tell you who walked away with that old tech video camcorder and still has it to this day. What is it? Randy Cordray.
是的。因为唯一能劝住迈克尔的人只有迈克尔。是的。如果你注意到艾伦使用的摄像机，那是有点过时的科技。我可以告诉你是谁拿走了那个过时的摄像机并且至今还保留着它。是什么？兰迪·科德雷。
Randy! Yes. He said that Phil Shea gave it to him when he left the series at the end of season seven. The camera, the case, the extra batteries, all the lenses, he still has it and he has used that tiny camcorder for insert shots on other series he's produced. He said that is his confessional to us, but he agreed that I could share it with you all. So when you want to know what did Randy get when he left, he got this camcorder. Wow.
兰迪！是的。他说菲尔·谢伊在第七季结束离开剧组时把它送给了他。摄像机、包、备用电池、所有的镜头，他都还留着，而且他在他制作的其他剧集里一直用那个小摄像机来拍插页镜头。他说这是他向我们的忏悔，但他同意我可以和你们所有人分享。所以当你想知道兰迪离开时得到了什么时，他得到了这个摄像机。哇。
Well, he also shared that the video footage you see of Michael was really shot on that little camera. Yeah. Pam has a big idea. She's coming in hot today. Yeah, she is. She has made a giant board with lots of glitter. I mean, the glitter is blinding.
好吧，他还分享说，你看到的迈克尔的视频画面确实是用那个小相机拍的。是的。帕姆有个大计划。她今天来势汹汹。是的，她确实如此。她做了一个巨大的看板，上面有很多亮片。我的意思是，那些亮片闪闪发光。
It really is. There's so much. There's blinding Angela. There's like a combo Dwight Angela sass in this moment because Dwight says, did your baby draw it? And then Angela's like, the glitter is blinding. There's such jerks to Pam. Pam wants everybody to write a New Year's resolution and then she's going to display
真的太闪了。闪得安吉拉都快瞎了。在这个时刻，德怀特和安吉拉有一种联合吐槽的感觉，因为德怀特说：“是你的宝宝画的吗？”然后安吉拉说：“亮片太刺眼了。”他们对帕姆真是太刻薄了。帕姆想让每个人都写下一个新年决心，然后她会把它们展示
them on her glittery resolution board. Well, you know who she was inspired by. Sue. Sue, in Vance refrigeration. Yeah. Sue has a motivation board. Yeah. Jenna, I always look in the candy bag alts to see who had the most alts for that episode.
在她闪亮的决心板上。好吧，你知道她受谁启发吗？苏。文斯制冷公司的苏。是的。苏有一个激励看板。是的，詹娜，我总是去看糖果袋废案，看看谁那一集的废案最多。
Okay. It's usually Dwight. Yes. Right? Yes. This episode, it was Pam. Were they all Sue talking heads? They were all Sue and they were must shoot.
好的。通常是德怀特。对吧？是的。这一集，是帕姆。全都是苏的独白吗？全都是苏的，而且是必拍镜头。
So you said all of this. Do you want to hear some of them? Yes. I'll see if I remember. Okay. If Sue can do it, why can't I? Sue's really cool. Sue just goes for it.
所以你把这些全说了。你想听听其中的一些吗？想。我看看我能不能记住。好的。如果苏能做到，我为什么不能？苏真的很酷。苏就是那种说干就干的人。
She's awesome. Sue is like the happiest person I've ever met. I want to be the happiest person I've ever met. I sort of have a girl crush on Sue. I want Sue to be my aunt or my best friend. Actually, I just want to be Sue and she makes her own sweaters and she gave me the best sugar cookie ever and Sue is just awesome. I love Sue.
她太棒了。苏是我见过最快乐的人。我想成为我见过最快乐的人。我对苏有点像女粉丝对偶像那种崇拜。我希望苏是我的阿姨或者我最好的朋友。其实，我只想成为苏，她会自己织毛衣，她给了我吃过最好吃的糖块，而且苏就是太棒了。我爱苏。
She has three different scissors that cut three different patterns into construction paper. How lame slash cool is that? I just want to steal a bunch of ideas from Sue. Then maybe come up with my own Sue type ideas. Then maybe I'll become Sue. I want to be more like Sue. And love Sue.
她有三把不同的剪刀，可以在手工纸上剪出三种不同的图案。这有多逊/多酷啊。我只想从苏那里偷走一堆想法。然后也许想出我自己的“苏式”想法。然后也许我就能变成苏。我想变得更像苏。我爱苏。
And lastly, I just left her office with such a strong impression that I need to be more like Sue. These are hilarious. You said all of that. There was a writer who was in charge of writing alternate talking heads. They would get assigned. You know, they'd say, hey, listen, here's the talking head in the script, but write a bunch of alts.
最后，我离开她的办公室时留下了如此深刻的印象，以至于我觉得我需要更像苏。这些太搞笑了。你把这些全说了。有一个负责写备用独白的编剧。他们会被分配任务。你知道的，他们会说，嘿，听着，剧本里有这个独白，但多写几个备选。
And then they'd sometimes put one or two in the candy bag. Clearly this person was on a roll. Oh yeah. Oh my gosh. Well, incidentally, Sue was played by Teresa Brown, who was a lovely woman. Phyllis doesn't like Sue. Phyllis doesn't like any woman that works at Vance Refrigeration. No.
然后他们有时会把一两个放进糖果袋里。显然这个人当时文思泉涌。哦，是的。哦，天哪。顺便说一句，苏由特雷莎·布朗饰演，她是一位可爱的女士。菲莉丝不喜欢苏。菲莉丝不喜欢任何在文斯制冷公司工作的女性。不。
Immediately a sworn enemy of Phyllis. Correct. Now we have a scene where Erin is helping Michael assign things to a happy box or a sad box. She has these bags. She's taking all these items out. For those of you guys who love to track things, in the happy box, we have champagne and gummy worms.
立刻成为菲莉丝不共戴天的仇人。没错。现在我们看到一个场景，艾伦正在帮迈克尔把东西分门别类放到快乐盒或悲伤盒里。她拿着这些袋子。她把所有的东西都拿出来了。对于你们这些喜欢追踪细节的人来说，在快乐盒里，我们有香槟和软糖。
It looks like maybe some giant like gloves, like, you know, like Mickey Mouse hands. I don't know. Okay. In the sad box, there's a sponge, gummy bears, a ukulele, and two bottles of scotch. And there's tickets to see Paula Poundstone for the happy box, for the happy box. We had a fan question from Jonathan S. in Poughkeepsie, New York. Please tell us everything about the Paula Poundstone tickets. I'm from Poughkeepsie, and Paula was actually there around the time this episode aired.
看起来好像还有一些巨大的手套，你知道的，就像米老鼠的手套那种。我不知道。好吧。在悲伤盒里，有一个海绵、小熊软糖、一把乌克丽丽和两瓶苏格兰威士忌。还有去看保拉·庞德斯通（Paula Poundstone）演出的门票，在快乐盒里，在快乐盒里。我们收到了来自纽约州波基普西市乔纳森·S的粉丝提问。请告诉我们关于保拉·庞德斯通门票的一切。我来自波基普西，这一集播出的时候，保拉确实在那里。
How did this reference come about? Well, Jonathan, I'm not sure why they chose Paula Poundstone, but Paula Poundstone is a comedian, and comedy and humor are how Michael and Holly bond. So I think it makes sense that they would go to see a comedian. Yes. I totally see that as a perfect date for them. Yes. Angela, I reached out to you earlier this week with a question.
这个梗是怎么来的？好吧，乔纳森，我不确定他们为什么选择保拉·庞德斯通，但保拉·庞德斯通是一位喜剧演员，而喜剧和幽默正是迈克尔和霍莉建立感情的方式。所以我认为他们去看喜剧演员演出是很合情合理的。是的。我完全觉得这对他们来说是一场完美的约会。是的。安吉拉，我这周早些时候带着一个问题联系了你。
You did, Jenna. I wanted to know, what would you put in your happy and sad boxes? And I thought I could think about it as well, and then we would share. Okay. So here was my question to you, that I didn't write you back. I thought we'd talk it out here in front of everybody. Are they objects? Are they experiences?
你确实这么做了，詹娜。我想知道，你会把什么放进你的快乐盒和悲伤盒里？我想我也可以考虑一下，然后我们来分享。好吧。所以这就是我问你的问题，我当时没有回信给你。我想我们可以在大家面前把它讨论出来。它们是物品吗？它们是经历吗？
Well, like tickets to Paula Poundstone is an experience. Yeah. I did a combo. Okay. Well, for me, it's interesting because the first thing I thought of when I really just sat and got quiet about my happy and my sad box, I have an item that goes in both. What is it? So when I'm really happy, I love to go for a walk.
嗯，就像保拉·庞德斯通的门票就是一种经历。是的。我做了一个组合。好吧。对我来说，这很有趣，因为当我真正坐下来，为我的快乐盒和悲伤盒静下心来时，我脑海中想到的第一件事是一个可以两边都放的物品。是什么？所以当我真的很开心的时候，我喜欢去散步。
I love plants, you guys. I'm just going to be that old lady that someday all my posts are going to be plants. Someday. Someday. It's happening now. Plants and hummingbirds. So when I'm happy, I love to go for a walk. But when I'm sad, I also love to go for a walk because I walk and I sort of journal internally
我喜欢植物，伙计们。我以后一定会变成那种老太太，总有一天我的所有动态都会是植物。总有一天。就是现在。植物和蜂鸟。所以当我开心的时候，我喜欢去散步。但当我难过的时候，我也喜欢去散步，因为我一边走一边在内心写日记，
and I just, I need distance from like everything around me and I just need to get out, get out of my head, get into my body. And so in both my happy and sad box would be a nice long walk. No, I had a lot of crossover when I sat down to think about what do I want when I'm happy and what do I want when I'm sad. And I could put a lot of similar items in both as well. Isn't that interesting? Yeah.
而且我，我需要与周围的一切保持距离，我只需要出去，走出我的脑袋，进入我的身体。所以我的快乐盒和悲伤盒里都会有一场美好漫长的散步。不，当我坐下来思考我开心时想要什么、难过时想要什么时，我有很多重叠的想法。而且我也可以在两边放很多相似的物品。这不是很奇妙吗？是的。
Is there anything else in your happy and sad boxes? So I thought really long and hard about this, Jenna, because I wanted to do a good job with your question. I felt like you were like by school teacher, I'm like, okay, I want to come prepare. I've given an assignment. And when I really thought about objects that bring me happiness or help me when I'm sad, I don't really attach a lot of emotion to objects. It's always people for me.
你的快乐盒和悲伤盒里还有别的吗？詹娜，我为此思考了很长时间，很深刻，因为我想很好地回答你的问题。我觉得你就像我的学校老师，我在想，好吧，我想做个有准备的人。我接到了一项作业。当我真正思考那些能带给我快乐或在我难过时能帮助我的物品时，我对物品其实并没有寄托太多的情感。对我和我来说，永远都是人。
I'm a people person. So when I get good news, I want to be around the people I love. When I get sad news, I want to be around the people I love. So I sort of, I cling to people, you know? But if I had to just sort of, okay, what would Michael Scott, you know, put in his box of objects? My happy box, if I got some great news, would probably be a wonderful glasses, I'm no blank. Okay.
我是个重感情的人。当我听到好消息时，我想和爱我的人在一起。当我听到悲伤的消息时，我想和爱我的人在一起。所以我有点，我依恋人，你知道吗？但如果我必须勉强，好吧，迈克尔·斯科特会把什么东西放进他的物品盒里呢？我的快乐盒，如果我得到了什么好消息，可能会是一个精美的酒杯，我不知道。好吧。
Maybe a donut. Good news. Let's get donuts. Maybe it would be a hummingbird feeder. Oh my gosh. And my sad box would probably be, I have a bathrobe. Josh has been like, Ang, you need to get rid of that bathrobe. It's on its last legs.
也许是一个甜甜圈。好消息。我们去吃甜甜圈吧。也许会是一个蜂鸟喂食器。哦，天哪。而我的悲伤盒可能会是，我有一件浴袍。乔什一直说：“安，你需要把那件浴袍扔了。它已经快穿烂了。”
It has a hole in the arm from when our dog was a puppy, it nod a hole, doesn't matter to me. It is also, I think, sentimental to me because it was a wrap gift on the office. So it's our blue robe that we got. It says the office on it. I know this robe. Yeah. It's really old now.
袖子上有个洞，那是我们家的狗还是小狗的时候咬出来的洞，对我来说没关系。它对我来说也很有纪念意义，因为它是《办公室》杀青时的礼物。所以那是我们得到的蓝色长袍。上面写着《办公室》。我知道这件浴袍。是的。现在真的很旧了。
Josh even gave me a new robe for Christmas last year that I don't wear. But when I'm sad, that robe has just journeyed through so much. And I just wrap it around me like a cloak and I get cozy. It's like you're blanky. It's like my blanky. So I would put on that robe, maybe make myself a cup of tea. Okay. Have a moment.
去年圣诞节乔什甚至给我买了一件新浴袍，但我都不穿。但当我难过的时候，那件长袍陪伴我经历了太多的风风雨雨。我只是把它像斗篷一样裹在身上，然后我就觉得很舒服。就像你的小毛毯一样。就像我的小毛毯。所以我可能会穿上那件长袍，给自己泡杯茶。好吧。好吧。
All right. All right. So I've got Samuel Blanc in a donut and then a hummingbird feeder and a cozy robe. And a cup of tea. And a cup of tea. All right. I like it. Well, when I was preparing my boxes, I was reminded of the fact that Michael also has
好的。所以我有一个Samuel Blanc、一个甜甜圈，然后是一个蜂鸟喂食器、一件舒适的长袍。还有一杯茶。还有一杯茶。好的。我很喜欢。好吧，当我准备我的盒子时，我想起了迈克尔也为他的快乐盒和悲伤盒预先选择好了音乐。所以我做了同样的事。哦，你选了音乐。是的。你想让我从快乐盒开始还是悲伤盒开始？
music that he's pre-selected for his happy and sad boxes. So I did the same thing. Oh, you did music. Yeah. Do you want me to start with my happy box or my sad box? I need a moment where I need to grow up because every time you say happy box and sad box, I just want to say that's what she said. I'm so sorry.
我需要缓一缓，因为每次你说快乐盒和悲伤盒时，我都只想说“她就是这么说的”。我很抱歉。而且当你说你必须准备你的盒子时，对不起。我只是把这些都说出来了。我只是把这些都发泄出来了。好吧。詹娜，让我们听听你的悲伤盒。好吧。
And when you said you had to prepare your box, I'm sorry. I'm just getting it all out. I'm getting it all out. Okay. Jenna, let's hear about your sad box. All right. Adam, could I please get my sad box audio? Of course.
亚当，能请播放我的悲伤盒音频吗？当然。什么？嗯哼。“靛蓝女孩”（Indigo Girls）是你的悲伤盒？对。我正试图对你诉说我生活中的一些事。你知道我在说什么吗？我离释怀更近了，但我快撑不下去了。我快撑不下去了。
What? Mm-hmm. Indigo Girls is your sad box? Yeah. I'm trying to tell you something about my life. You know what I'm saying? I'm closer to fine, but I'm losing it. I'm losing it.
所以我要把这首歌声音放大。好的。这是我的悲伤赞歌。我需要把这首歌一直听到“离释怀更近了”。詹娜，我妈妈几年前结婚时就是伴着这首歌走进婚礼教堂的。什么？别这样！
So I crank this song. Okay. This is my sad anthem. I need to hear it all the way to closer to fine. Jenna, my mom walked down the aisle to this song when she got married a couple of years back. What? Stop it!
等等！詹娜的悲伤盒里的歌是你妈妈的？嗯-huh。走向婚姻和爱情的歌？你难道不知道这首歌最近吗？那是几年前。哦，天哪。我的意思是，我觉得这首歌听起来非常像，就像是在说“我会挺过去的”。
Wait! Jenna's sad box was your mom's? Uh-huh. Walk to marriage and love? Don't you know this song recently? They're a couple of years back. Oh, my God. I mean, I find this song to be like very, like, I'm going to make it.
就像一条毛毯。我脑海中浮现出你年轻时放声高歌的画面。漫步在海岸边。我去看过医生，我去过群山，我看着孩子们，我从喷泉里饮水。然后这些问题只有一个答案，指引着我走向一条蜿蜒的线。我离我的根源越远，我就离释怀越近。是的。
Like a blanket. I just picture you as a young woman just belting this out. Rolling on your shores. I went to the doctor, I went to the mountains, I looked to the children, I drank from the fountains. Then one answer to these questions pointing me in a crooked line. And the less I see my source, the closer I am to fine. Yeah.
好吗？哦，天哪。好的，所以这首歌在播放，以下是我从盒子里拿出来的东西。我刚才都不知道自己有多需要在这个早晨听到“靛蓝女孩”的歌。你的悲伤盒里有什么？随着这首歌的播放，以下是即将从里面拿出来的东西。准备好了吗？嗯-huh。
Okay? Oh, my God. Okay, so this song is playing and here are the items that I'm taking out of my box. I didn't know how much I needed to hear the Indigo Girls this morning. What's in your sad box? Here's what's coming out of it as we're listening to this song. Are you ready? Uh-huh.
一颗沐浴炸弹。好的。一张面膜。好的。一套干净舒适的睡衣。我们在浴袍这件事上想法不谋而合。一整套《娇妻》真人秀。哦，那是你。
A bath bomb. Okay. A facial mask. Okay. A clean pair of cozy pajamas. We're in the same ballpark with the robe. Box set of real housewives. Oh, that's you.
冰淇淋和随时可以拨通的安吉拉的电话。哦，天哪。我的悲伤盒，各位。哦，你也会在我的快速拨号里。好了，我们该换个档位，去看看我的快乐盒了吗？我求之不得。这是我的快乐盒的歌。是的。
Ice cream and Angela on speed dial. Oh, lady. My sad box, folks. Oh, you would be on my speed dial, too. All right, should we switch gears and head over to my happy box? I'd love nothing more. Here's my happy box song. Yes.
我们在播放性感复古。哦， yeah。哦， yeah。哦，天哪，现在正扭动着身体呢。好吧，以下是我从快乐盒里拿出来的东西。好的。我要把性感带回来。把性感带回来。
We're in sexy bath. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, my goodness, shimmying right now. All right, here's what's coming out of my happy box. Okay. I'm bringing sexy back. Bring in sexy back.
好吧。什么？这里有一杯老式鸡尾酒（Old Fashioned）。有一家很棒的餐厅的品尝菜单预订，他们为我准备好了无麸质菜单。有一份我的歌曲的舞曲播放列表，而这首歌排在最前面。有一大瓶水和两片阿司匹林。因为你喝了老式鸡尾酒。
All right. What? Here, there's an old-fashioned. There's a reservation for a tasting menu at a great restaurant that has pre-prepared me a gluten-free menu. There is a dance party playlist of my songs, of which this is at the top. There is a large bottle of water and two Advil. Because you've had an old-fashioned.
而且我要跳一整夜的舞。最后，是随时可以拨通的安吉拉的电话。呜呼！就是这样。我太喜欢了。别太自恋了。我曾经见过贾斯汀·汀布莱克一次。你见过？
And I'm going to be dancing all night. And finally, Angela on speed dial. Woo! There you go. I love it. Don't head peak on with it. I met Justin Timberlake once. You did?
对，一次。是在艾美奖后台，不，我是说后台。是在艾美奖的后台。还记得我是怎么总能设法让我们钻到颁奖嘉宾的那扇幕帘后面的吗？我们在《办公室闺蜜》里写过这件事，有一次我们把劳伦斯·菲什伯恩惹毛了。我的意思是，听着，对劳伦斯·菲什伯恩公平一点说，我们当时正在狼吞虎咽地吃东西，而他正准备上台。哦，不，不。
Yeah, once. It was backstage at the, no, I was the mess. It was backstage at the Emmys. Remember how I would always manage to get us behind that curtain for the presenters? We wrote about it in Office BFFs, where we pissed off Lawrence Fishburne that one time. I mean, listen, to be fair to Lawrence Fishburne, we were devouring food and he was about to go on stage. Oh, no, no.
我们完全有错。不，不。我们真的是，我的意思是，但是是的，你总是能找到名人们的这些犄角旮旯，把我们塞进去。而我从来都不酷。那是我偶遇贾斯汀·汀布莱克的地方。我什么也没说。我只是。
We were completely at fault. No, no. We were total, I mean, but yes, you always found these nooks and crannies of famous people and got us in there. And I was never cool. That's where I ran into Justin Timberlake. I said nothing. I just.
听起来很符合。我只是。我只是。在这个房间里和他共处了一会儿，然后就结束了。保佑你，贾斯汀。他甚至都不知道。不，他不知道。他不知道。
That sounds right. I just did. I just did. Existed in the room with him for a moment and then it was over. Bless you, Justin. He doesn't even know. No, he doesn't. He doesn't know.
他根本不知道“性感复古”对我的快乐盒有多大影响力。快乐盒。贾斯汀，你懂她的快乐盒。哦，我早就知道话题要往这儿发展了。好吧。我要出去了。我待会儿再进来。好吧。
He doesn't know how influential sexy back is for my happy box. Happy box. Justin, you feel her happy box. Oh, I knew that's where that was going. All right. I'm going to step out. I'll come back in. All right.
我们该回到正题上来了吗？我们大概应该这样。好的。艾伦在面对镜头独白时，说她对迈克尔无论如何都很兴奋。他要么会非常幸福，要么会避免他一生中最大的错误。是的。艾伦就是不喜欢霍莉。一点也不。
Should we get back on track here? We probably should. Okay. I'm going to talk in head where she says she's excited for Michael either way. He's either going to be really happy or avoid the biggest mistake of his life. Yes. Heron just does not like Holly. At all.
你猜谁要戴着巨大的连指手套来上班了？把手套摘下来，女人。我喜欢聚在她周围、护送她从前门一直走回座位的那些人群。我也很喜欢。我女儿伊莎贝尔，你知道的，她喜欢NG镜头，她在这里给我们提供了一个NG镜头警报。当凯文说“祝贺毕业”然后掉了东西时，明迪当场笑场得太厉害了。这在NG镜头里。
And guess who's about to come to work with giant mittens on? Remove the mittens, woman. I love the crowd of people that all forms around her and walks her from the front door all the way back to her desk. I did too. My daughter, Isabel, you know, who loves bloopers gave us a blooper alert here. When Kevin says, can graduate and he drops off, Mindy broke so hard on that. It's in the bloopers.
我会把它发到快拍里。霍莉终于意识到每个人都知道最后通牒的事了。凯利承认了。是的，我告诉所有人了。詹娜，这里本来有一个凯利面对镜头的独白。它在糖果袋废案的必拍镜头里。真的把我逗笑了。
I'll put it in stories. Holly is going to realize that everyone knows about the ultimatum. Kelly admits. Yeah. I told everyone. Jenna, there was a Kelly talking head that would have come here. It was in the candy bag alts must shoot. It really made me laugh.
我想读一下。凯利看着镜头说：“是的，我和所有人说了霍莉跟AJ的deal。你们干嘛还问我？从今以后，如果有什么秘密泄露了，或者传播了恶毒的谣言，或者有人受伤了，直接把我的名字记在‘是的，我干的’这个永久名单上吧。我没时间理这破事。”好吧，当霍莉终于脱下连指手套并举起无名指时，凯文误解了
I want to read it. Kelly looks to Cameron says, yes, I told everyone about Holly's deal with AJ. Why do you even ask me anymore? From now on, if a secret gets spilled or malicious lies get spread or someone gets hurt, just put me down as a permanent. Yes, I did it. I don't have time for this. Well, when Holly finally takes off her mittens and she holds up her ring finger, Kevin misinterprets
我想读一下。凯利看着卡梅伦说，是的，我把霍利和AJ的交易告诉了所有人。你为什么还要问我？从现在开始，如果有秘密泄露、恶毒的谣言散播或者有人受伤，就把我记作永久的嫌疑人。是的，我干的。我没时间理这些。嗯，当霍利终于脱下手套，举起无名指时，凯文误解了
this and thinks that she's flipping him off. So then he flips her off. This is strike two for Kevin with Holly first, the maple candy, now the finger. I have two words. Oh, no, standards and practices. Starting with the table draft, they noted that this was scripted and said, please blur Kevin's hands when he gives the middle finger gesture, quote unquote, you to Holly. Then they reviewed our shooting draft.
Scene was still in there. So they said, as previously noted, and they repeated their note. But for some reason, and here's what I don't understand. We must have turned in our editor's cut and we hadn't blurred it yet, maybe because you don't send it off for blurring, you know, you don't send it in until after you fully locked the episode. But just to be sure that we didn't forget, they said again, blur Kevin's hands when he flips her the bird.
Did they write the bird? They wrote the bird. They wrote the bird, quote unquote, you. They like really drove it home. Like I want you to know, just want to know, I want a visual image of who is writing these emails. I so need to see who this person is. As previously stated, I need to see this person.
I know. Angela Martin would have been great in standards and practices. Oh, that's who works there. There's your spin off Angela Martin standards and practices. No lip flap. Blur lip flap. Well this flipping of the ring finger is going to set off a huge chain reaction. Michael is so excited.
He runs into his office. It's a full on celebration. Happy, happy, happy. There's music, there's confetti, there's champagne, like start the happy video. He's talking himself down. It's mayhem. Did we all notice that Erin gets sprayed with champagne but doesn't look drenched the rest of the day?
I did not notice that but yes, she gets completely drenched. We got fan questions about it. Teresa M. in Chicago said, I love the scene of Michael and Erin celebrating. It is pure joy. Did Steve really shake up a bottle of champagne or was it a special effect? It was real you guys and it was all scripted. You know what they did was they would shoot the top of the scene over and over and over and over again and once they were sure that they got it, then they would move on to the
champagne part. So that's how they do that. But she still did have to change and they did it more than once. The song that is playing is Kelly Clark since My Life Would Suck Without You. Guess how much it costs to play that song for Michael to be happy? So much money. I want to guess. I want to guess.
I want to guess. It's under a hundred thousand. But still so much. I was going to say twenty five thousand dollars. Forty thousand dollars. Wow. Yeah. Wow.
It's one of our more expensive songs. But guess what? It's not the most expensive song in this episode. I'll get to it. No way. Yes way. Oh my God. Listen how high my voice is.
Yeah. Sorry everyone that's listening with headphones. Pam is now going to go around and collect everyone's resolution cards but Dwight refuses to participate. He's such a stinker. He says he's achieved plenty. Andy's resolution is to learn to cook for one. Sad sack.
Yeah. Angela walks up proudly and puts her card on the board. It says to make time for romance with the senator. And that sets Dwight off. Dwight's resolution is now suddenly to meet loose women. Andy says I'll take that. And then Daryl says they should go to a bookstore at lunch time. He says that he does this bit where he says hey what book is that cool let's hang out
tonight. Ooh sex already. Whoa. There was a candy bag all for this. Okay. It's so good. And Craig had several. So whatever his bit was with the ladies he had a bunch.
Here was one. You know what you guys should go to the bookstore at lunch. Tons of cuties and it's easy to talk to them. Hey you know where the sex books are? Want to see if mine's published yet? Girl voice. Damn. You wrote the book on sex.
Daryl shrugs. Right what you know. Hi. I'm Daryl. We got quite a bit of fan mail about this scene. People were really obsessed with the resolution cards themselves. So first up from Serena M. in Vancouver, Canada. Did the props team come up with different handwritings for the New Year's resolution
cards or did the actors write them themselves? I have a very strong memory of Phil handing me several index cards and asking me to write my resolution. And I zoomed in and when I look at the card it looks like my handwriting. What about you, Ange? You know I do remember. I remember he passed out note cards to all of us and if you zoom in on the board you see a lot of different types of handwriting styles.
That is mine and I even recognize Reigns. Michael is going to go over to Holly's desk. Holly has a new phone but you know you guys, she misses her old phone. This starts a whole ET phone home bit. I rewound it. I think I watched it four times. I was laughing so hard. I did that laugh where you shake but you don't really make noise like that's how much this
got me. I think because growing up I loved the movie ET. I saw it like eight times and then my friends and I used to always do ET to each other. It's so sweet. I love it. Can we please hear it? Oh, somebody's got a new phone. Yeah.
That is neat. I got it for Christmas. I'm so out of my link here. ET phone, Holly. Holly like phone. Holly misses old phone. Why? New phone is confusing, gets bad reception.
Oh, bummer. Bummer. Reeses pieces. Reeses pieces. Oh God, please stop. Poor Kelly. That made me laugh so hard. Reeses pieces.
Oh my God, stop. Finally, someone is annoying Kelly. Right? But then she gets a call on her new phone. It's AJ. They start talking about movies. They're going to go see. It's clear they're still together.
She says she loves him. Michael does that slow fade away. He's heartbroken. And did you notice the whole scene? He had the tickets to Paula Poundstone in his hand. I didn't. He was going to ask her. I know.
I did not catch that. Michael's really sad now. He's going to go talk to Pam. Yes. He's curious. Is it possible that she's already dating a different person named AJ? And that's who she's talking to. Pam says that is not likely.
Phyllis is going to offer to help. And Michael says, you think she'd talk to you? Phyllis says, why wouldn't she? And he said, that's true. She's really nice. She'd talk to anybody. Angela, this exchange, this like weird dig. I witnessed something like this happen on the playground.
What? Between two moms, we were in a little conversation. Yeah. And one of the moms said, your daughter is so sweet to my daughter. I just love their interaction. I was just complimenting this woman's daughter. And she said, oh yeah, my daughter's nice to anyone. Oh no.
And I was like, I was like, what? And I saw the look on the original mom's face. And she made eye contact with me as if to say, did we both clock that? Yeah. Just such a passive dig. It is. Oh my goodness. Yes.
Well, there's Michaels everywhere, you guys. Well, I think we should take a break because when we get back, the guys are going to arrive at the bookstore. And they're going to devise a plan to meet some ladies. We'll be right back. We're back. We're in the bookstore. Did anyone else notice at nine minutes and 59 seconds how much the wind was blowing in
the trees outside? No. Was this just me? It was a windy day. Very windy. I went to the call sheet, Jenna. What? Yeah.
And did it say, because it would say wind, advisory. We filmed the scene around 11 a.m. on October 25th, 2010. And the gusts were up to seven miles an hour that day. Oh my goodness. Well, there you go. There was some wind. We had a fan question from Tori N in Concord, North Carolina. Tell us about Ellen, the bookstore lady.
That's right. Daryl walks right up to a woman. She has a tag that says Ellen, and she's going to pitch the e-reader to Daryl. They can hold 10,000 books. I mean, Daryl is blown away. He says it's so light. It's like a croissant. Ellen was played by Martha Middleton.
She has also appeared on To Tell the Truth as one of the imposters. Oh, no way. Yes, and also in the film, The Newcomers. Dwight and Andy are going to start scoping it out. They've gone upstairs. And a pretty lady is going to walk by. Yes. They try to pick her up, but she mistakes them as employees.
They're doing a very bad job. They're so awkward. Guess, Star Alert, that bookstore customer is Ed's wife, Sarah. Yeah. How about that? I love how we would have our friends and family on the show because you go back. You have all these memories. Yes, like how our camera assistant, Ed, was in the cold open.
I know. At the beginning. It's the best. We also had a fan catch from Emily J and Ohio and many others. At 10 minutes and 39 seconds, Angela, did you notice? There is a whole display of Joe Bennett's book. No. It's a great detail.
Oh, that's so great. That little detail was courtesy of Dave Rogers. That was his idea. Dave, who knows the show better than Dave? Nobody. Nobody. Next up, Phyllis is going to become a mom detective. She's got a salad to go.
She says, Aaron, follow my lead. And she's going to share that she went to Portugal. I was very intrigued by this. Aaron, who's a horrible wingman, said, so did I. I went to Portugal. And Holly's like, wow, together. And Phyllis is like, no. Yeah, there are sort of exchanging stories about what's happened over the new year.
They're trying to drag it out of Holly. What happened that might be interesting about your new year? Holly gets it. And she says, yeah, I didn't uphold my ultimatum deadline. She said, but it was unfair of me to give him an ultimatum. In the meantime, Dwight, Andy, and Darryl have ditched the bookstore. It didn't go well. Dwight has driven them to a strip club.
He said he is going to see his resolution through today. I've got a little bit of location information about the strip club temptation. OK. This was a real strip club in Northridge, California. And it was actually across the street from the roller rink. Our locations manager, Kyle Alexander, managed to find this very specific thing, which was a strip club across the street from a roller rink. That's just crazy luck.
Because I asked Randy, I said, oh, so did we have to make this? Because surely that's, you know, Randy said no. He really found that location. However, he said that the location did not look like a strip club. It was just sort of a gray building. The only sign telling you that it was temptation was a sign on a pole. So they asked the club, can we kind of judge up your exterior? Michael Gallenberg created that giant temptation sign.
I have a question. Was it temptation or temptations? I'm just curious. Just a background catch question for you guys. I think it's called temptation. OK. Gentleman's club. One temptation.
There's only one per customer. OK. You know, there's one giant temptation. And it's coming into this club at all. The flesh. Yes, that's right. And Michael Gallenberg based that logo on the outside of the building. On their real logo, he painted the front of the building a combination of red and gray.
Randy even showed us the before and after pictures. It's a great judge, I have to say. Randy said that after it was over, you know, it's in our contract. We have to restore things to their original condition. The managers of temptation said, no, thank you. Keep it up. We love it. Well, yeah.
But it is now closed. It doesn't exist anymore. It's an empty building for lease. It's gray again now. So it's a blank slate waiting to be something. Something new. And incidentally, there is a temptations nightclub in Scranton, but it is a dance club and bar. There's no fleshy temptations.
Right. There's no singular temptation. That's right. Daryl says, hold up. I don't have anything against strip clubs, but I don't really want to go on Monday at noon. Yes, that's correct. Andy spots a roller skating rink and says, hey, how about there? Single ladies at the rink.
So they go and they're the only three people there. It's just the three of them skating around. Angela, you mentioned the call sheets for this episode. I noticed some notes on the call sheets for this episode. What did they say? Rain had to take roller skating lessons. Two different days to prepare for this episode. So I texted Rain about it and he said, yes.
He said, I had to do the lessons because I hadn't skated since the late 1970s. Well, I did notice that he's the only one with elbow pads and knee pads. I think that might be why. He's also the only one that had to then skate outside. Yes. I brought something fun today. You brought more things in. Is it Santa Kins 2?
I'm not prepared for another round. It's not Santa Kins. Clearly I've become now like carrot top of the podcast and you guys can't see this, but we'll put it in stories. I brought my OG roller skates. What? That I have had since I was 24. You guys, my roller skates are older than some of you listening.
I still skate. Jenna was right. I brought them in and it's my intention to skate through Ear Wolf today. Hey, I like this. These are old school exterior roller skates. They're great for if you go out on the street. They look really weathered because guys, I love them. Come on.
I'm a kid of the 70s. It just occurred to me now that there probably is a difference between exterior and interior skates. Yes. These are exterior skates and they just kind of grip the road better. These are what I skate around my neighborhood in. We can continue the podcast. I'm going to put them on. You're going to put on these roller skates and when we're done with this podcast,
we're going to end with you roller skating through Ear Wolf. Today is the busiest day at Ear Wolf I've ever seen. There are more people here than ever. There's two major conference room meetings happening. I look forward to this footage. I can't wait. Don't tell anyone in the conference room. I'm just going to skate by.
The other day, I had come in here on a Sunday to get some work done and no one was here. And I called Josh, I said, babe, no one is here. And he goes, do you wish you had your roller skates? Because he knows whenever I see a big open area, like at the airport, when you have to walk down a long, long tunnel, I'm always like, I wish I had my roller skates. Oh, I want you to start taking your roller skates with you to the airport. That would be amazing. I feel like we should check back in on the conference room because Pam is having a meeting
to check in with everyone about their resolutions. Yes. Aaron's resolution is going immensely. Her resolution of learning a new word each day. Yes, Pam tosses her a congratulation, Frisbee. Yes, I guess. There's prizes for upholding your resolutions. Creed is going to share his resolution. It's one of my favorite speeches that Creed gives.
His performance is amazing. This is what he says. I want to do a cartwheel, but real casual like. Not make a big deal about it, but I know everybody saw it. Just one stunning, gorgeous cartwheel. And Pam says, how's it going? And Creed says, I'm having a little trouble motivating. Well, we had a fan catch from Carolyn M. in Indiana who says, background catch.
Stan Lee's New Year's resolution says, quote, be a better husband and boyfriend. Stan Lee. Do better at both. She said, I am sure you will all do a New Year's Eve, office ladies breakdown of all the resolutions. Carolyn, here it is. Yeah. Here is your breakdown of all of the resolutions on the board.
Michael Floss. Pam, drink less caffeine. Jim, bike more. Dwight, meet a loose woman. Angela, make more time for romance with the senator. In parentheses. Erin, learn a new word every single day. Gabe's resolution was be less squeamish around people's dogs and babies.
What's up with babies? Also terrified of cockroaches. I don't know. Andy, as we said, wants to learn to cook for one. Creed wants one amazing cartwheel. Phyllis wants to do yoga lessons with Bob. Aw. Oscar would like to finish the living room.
Meredith would like to get down to two cigarettes a day. Kelly would like to get more attention by any means necessary. Ryan is going to live life like it's an art project. Oh, Ryan. As we know, Darryl wants to read more. Holly wants to cross train. And finally, Kevin wants to eat more vegetables, which is going to come up now.
Because Pam is asking everyone, how are your resolutions doing? Michael is starting to spiral. And it's going to play out in front of everyone. He really can't handle when people don't follow through and do what they say they're going to do. That's right. He's going to take this all out on Kevin, who he says has to eat broccoli.
Now, it's going to happen. He sends Erin out to the kitchen. And I have this question. How long have giant broccoli stems been hanging out in the kitchen at Dunder Mifflin? And other odd vegetables. Yeah, I don't know. We just have to let it happen, guys.
We had a fan question from Lauren H in Florida. The scene where Michael force feeds Kevin the broccoli makes me laugh so hard. Brian was perfection. I need to know everything about this scene. Did he really eat it? Was this at all improvised? Lauren, everything was scripted.
Everything except for one thing at the very end. When he spews it everywhere, that wasn't scripted. And those reactions were real. Yes. And specifically, we had a fan question from Kristen H in Michigan who wanted to know when Brian Kevin is showing Steve Michael the broccoli under his tongue, is Brian breaking?
Kristen, yes. Yes. He was breaking through the filming of this entire moment. It was so absurd. It was so ridiculous. And also, he was trying not to gag. Yeah. How he was able to hold that much broccoli under his tongue
and then show Michael and flip his tongue up without choking, although he did almost choke one time. Remember? I do. We're like, give him water. It was a very, very funny scene the whole time. In the moment, I could see under his tongue, and it made me laugh every time he revealed it.
You might notice they do not have me on camera. I couldn't hold it together. Well, I was curious about what the most popular New Year's resolutions are each year. And here's what the internet had to say about 2022. Oh. Before I list them, I want you guys to know, the survey also said most people bail on their resolutions
two weeks into the year. I was going to say, I've heard this statistic that by February 1, people are cancelling all of their gym memberships. Here's what made the top list of resolutions for 2022. Number one, exercise more. Yes. That's the number one.
Number two, eat healthier. Number three, lose weight. Number four, spend more time with family and friends. Number five, live more economically. Number six, spend less time on social media. Number seven, reduce stress on your job. And the last one, to quit smoking. Wow.
I wanted to bring up, Angela, a little brag. Oh. For the two of us. Oh, okay. I believe being more physically active and getting exercise has been a resolution of our friendship since its inception. We've chronicled before on this podcast
how we have started many exercise routine together only to have them fail. But I want to brag on us because over the last few months you and I have both developed a routine. You go to tennis every Friday morning. Yep. And I do yoga every Friday morning. We are not exercising together.
But at the same time. Same time. On the same day. Yeah. So I'm very proud of us. I am too. And I'm always so happy to hear your message where you're like, I made it to yoga.
It was so great. And I'm like, lady, my backhand was happening today. I'm going to throw down a little yoga wisdom. Oh. My yoga instructor says this in every session at some point. And I love it. He says, find that place between ambition and acceptance and hover there.
Oh, I love that. Find a place between your ambition and your acceptance of where you are right now and hover there. I love it. I love that. I call my mom every Friday morning on my way to tennis because my mom was an amazing tennis player. I spent my childhood on a tennis court with her.
She was ranked by the USDA for her age group. She was amazing. So I always call her on my way to tennis and we talk. And before I get off the phone, I'm like, mom, I'm parking. And she'll say, all right, and go stick it in their ear. So. That's your phrase. That's your Friday phrase.
That's my Friday phrase. I love it. At the roller rink, Andy and Dwight are roller skating, but Daryl is hiding on the floor reading his new e-reader. Are you guys curious about what Daryl was reading? I am. Is there an answer? There was a candy bag alt must shoot where Daryl is talking
about his e-reader. He doesn't want Andy and Dwight to know about it. Of course not. They're the paper business. No, it read like this. They can never know. I can't leave it in the car. I can't check it with these teenage employees.
Got to just hang on to it. And if I'm going to do that, might as well read some John Crackauer. Oh, that's what Daryl was reading. Interesting. This is when Dwight decides to skate over to the strip club. Mm-hmm. He skates across the street very awkwardly.
If you need any evidence that rain hadn't skated in a while. Here's your evidence. So now Andy is the only one skating. The DJ asked him if he has any requests and he wants to hear some Dave Matthews Band deep tracks only. This was the pricey song. This is it. Guess how much the song Ants Marching by Dave Matthews Band
cost us. Well, you already said Kelly Clarkson was 40,000 and that this was more. It was more. I don't know. I don't know. Like I'm thinking of such a big number, but that's probably crazy.
50,000. Wow. Randy Cordray wanted to explain a few things about music licensing fees. We actually got a late breaking email from Randy about these high music fees in this episode. Late breaking email. Yes.
Randy said by the time we were producing episodes for the office, licensing fees had really gone through the roof. He said back in the day, if you were a popular musician with a good catalog of hit songs, you could make a very good living. Just living off your royalties and your publishing money. But this kind of changed in the late 1980s after the technology shift from vinyl records to CD. He said then Apple computers and early iterations of iTunes
allowed anybody to kind of rip digital content from a CD and start sharing it with someone else. So one person could buy a CD, but then share it with all their friends. Then of course we have internet platforms like Spotify that popped up where music was being shared over the internet. So now he said as we moved into the 2000s, artists in the music publishing firms saw film and television production
companies as industry. As a way to make money. Yeah, with really deep pockets. And so they started upping all the licensing fees. He said so if we wanted a song, we had to pay a lot of money for it. And also they would charge people differently. He said the same song on a different TV series.
It might go for less money, but we were a hit show. So when we asked for music, we got a big price tag. He said my long winded comments boil down to this. $50,000 for Dave Matthews was a lot of money, but it's what he asked for and it's what we were willing to pay. I'll say this, I am all for artists getting paid for their work. Yes.
And good for you. Good for you Dave Matthews. You know that coin fella. You hustle. Who am I now? I don't know. Get that coin fella. You're a combination of hipster and old lady at the same time.
You're like grandma who's learning some lingo. Oh my gosh. You know, Angie, if you thought I was finished with this scene, I'm not. What else you got? The guest star DJ at the skating rink was David Ferguson. He's a writer, actor, performer, a long time writer for comedy bang bang.
He's also been on the show Superstore and The Good Place. And finally, if you are impressed with Ed Helms' roller skating in this scene, he was having a good time and he did a bunch of takes of this. I was so envious of him. He had that whole ring to himself. I would have just been in heaven. I know you would.
He's doing little side to side. I can do that side to side. He did an interview with screen junkies after this episode filmed and he said, quote, I was so insanely sore the next day. It was just one of those things I hadn't done in 20 years and it hurts. That's what he said.
That's so funny. I don't get sore from roller skating, but you know, I can't do a push-up. So there's that. Michael knows he's messed up. He's going to talk to Kevin and Creed and apologize, but he wants Holly there because he's really apologizing to Holly.
Through Creed and Kevin. Creed says he doesn't know if he's ready to accept the apology. Yes. He said, sorry, sorry there, boss. I'm not sure if I'm there yet. Kevin is, gives him a huge hug. Holly leaves the room.
She's sad. Pam's going to walk out of the kitchen, and she's holding a can of soda. Uh-oh. What's wrong with the soda? She gave up caffeine. Oh, right. Right.
It's the crux of this scene. Kelly's going to notice and be like, what the heck? Also, Kevin has graffitied Ryan's card. He's made art into fart. He also then makes a fart noise. That then makes himself fart. His look to camera at 18 minutes 49 is so hilarious. There's a lot of tension over the resolution board,
and it's going to come to a peak. Things are getting heated. Meredith is starting to smoke. Aaron's going to come in and do a cartwheel. Creed's going to cuss her out. I texted with Creed about this. Creed said, you have to look at Phyllis' face when I start cursing. He said Phyllis had no idea that he was going to go off quite
like that, and her reaction is genuine. He said, and I quote, I was cursing like a sailor. Well, I went to the scene, and at 18 minutes 55 seconds, Phyllis' reaction is priceless. That is so funny, because this moment was scripted. In fact, in the script, it's written that Creed says, f**k you, and then f**k you again, and the second one's in all caps. So they really wanted him to ramp it up.
Yes, but Creed said that he kept going and going. Oh boy. Well, lady, guess what? Standards and practices. Oh yeah. They got involved, you know, from the minute that we turned in the script, but this time they had options for us. They said, options from S&P?
Options. They were willing to work with us on this one. When we turned in the table draft, here was their note. Please bleep with no beginning or end consonant sounds, and blur the visible lip flap, or stage Creed off-camera. So there's no lip flap? I guess so, for the f**k mentioned by Creed. Now, standards and practices.
How is this scene working if Creed is off-camera? What is happening? Just some bleeps? Just bleeps are happening? Of course, these notes went through every draft of the script, and at the very end we got your favorite, Angela, as previously noted, bleep completely and blur the lip flap when Creed says f**k to Erin after she does the cartwheel.
I want to say one thing to standards and practices. I think you guys type profanity in your emails more than anyone I've ever encountered. So for all of your rules and regulations, you let it fly in an email. It's true. Pam gives up. She's going to toss the resolution board into the dumpster.
Lesson learned. Yeah. Back at the roller rink, Andy has met someone. He did it. He met someone named Andy, and he skates like a Greek god. There was a candy bag alt for this moment where Andy says this. My resolution is to find someone,
and maybe I didn't do that today, but I have another resolution. It was almost my main resolution, and it is to exercise my calves. And if today is any indication, I think it's going to be a good year. Well, at the very end, the DJ is going to offer to put on the strobe light
so that the three of them can skate again. Randy told me that the song that was playing during this sequence of skating was free because they literally couldn't spend any more money on music, so they had to find a track that was under the public domain. The guys don't have their skates on, and they climb over the wall in socks, so they actually dance on the rink floor.
这样他们三个就能再次滑冰了。兰迪告诉我，这一段滑冰时放的歌是免费的，因为他们实在没钱买音乐了，所以他们必须找一首处于公有领域的曲目。这几个家伙没有穿冰鞋，而是穿着袜子爬过了墙，所以他们实际上是在冰场地板上跳舞。
They don't skate. Yes. But when they climbed over the wall with their socks, they all busted it and fell. Their socks were so slippery on the floor. It's in the bloopers. Of course, my daughter, Isabel, pointed it out. I'll have to put it in stories because it's pretty funny.
他们没有滑冰。是的。但当他们穿着袜子爬过墙时，他们都摔了个四脚朝天。他们的袜子在地板上太滑了。这在NG镜头里。当然，我的女儿伊莎贝尔指出来了。我得把它发到快拍里，因为太搞笑了。
When we go back to the office, Aaron's dealing with Michael's happy sad boxes, and Michael says that his resolution is to never make Holly cry again. Yeah, Holly is really sad. She's called AJ. She's told him, maybe we should just call it off for a bit, you know?
当我们回到办公室时，亚伦正在处理迈克尔的“悲喜交加盒”，迈克尔说他的决心是再也不让霍莉哭了。是的，霍莉真的很伤心。她给AJ打了电话。她告诉他，也许我们应该暂停一会儿，你知道的？
Yeah. There was a deleted scene where Pam tries to comfort her. It involves Hank. It's that caffeine corner, and Hank's clearly annoyed that they've picked this spot to have this conversation, and he keeps cranking the volume to the music that's playing to try to drown them out.
对。有一个被删掉的场景，帕姆试图安慰她。这涉及汉克。那是咖啡角，汉克显然很生气他们选了这个地方进行这次对话，他不断把正在播放的音乐音量调大，试图盖过他们的声音。
Listen to this. Hey, Holly. Hey. You okay? Yeah, I'm okay. How's the cocoa? It's great. It's the best.
听听这个。嘿，霍莉。嘿。你还好吗？是的，我很好。热可可怎么样？太棒了。这是最棒的。
Are you okay? I'm okay. I know you probably don't need my advice, but don't feel like you have to make any sort of decision today. Oh, I know. Honestly, it wasn't fair of me to give him an ultimatum in the first place, and the whole different cities thing.
你还好吗？我很好。我知道你可能不需要我的建议，但不要觉得你今天非得做出什么决定。哦，我知道。老实说，一开始我对他说最后通牒并不公平，而且还有异地恋的问题。
Yeah. You know, I thought Jim was going to propose a lot of times, and I kept on being wrong. But I knew it was the right guy, and that's all that mattered. Can I get my espresso? Can I get myself an illness? Wow.
是啊。你知道的，我以为吉姆会求婚很多次，但我一直都猜错。但我知道他是对的人，这才是最重要的。能给我来杯意式浓缩咖啡吗？能让我自己生病吗？哇。
Okay. Yeah. You and Amy and Hugh, we're having a good time over there. Listen, caffeine corner is not the place for heart to heart, all right? Get your coffee and go. Well, this episode is going to end
好吧。是的。你、艾米和休，你们在那边玩得很开心。听着，咖啡角可不是谈心的地方，好吗？拿上咖啡走吧。好吧，这一集将以
with Michael coaching Creed on how to do a cartwheel. Mm-hmm. Michael says he'll stay as long as it takes, and then Creed goes for it. He does it. We got a fan question from Emily C. in Australia, who said, I want to know everything there is to know about Creed
迈克尔指导克里德如何做侧手翻结束。嗯哼。迈克尔说他要呆到学会为止，然后克里德就去做了。他成功了。我们收到了来自澳大利亚的艾米莉·C的粉丝提问，她说，我想知道关于克里德
doing this cartwheel. Was it actually Creed? As a full-time gymnastics coach of 12 years, I'd like to say that while it's not the perfect cartwheel, it is a very good start, especially for a beginner. It has the correct direction and rhythm, which can be the hardest part.
做这个侧手翻的一切。真的是克里德本人吗？作为一名有12年经验的全职体操教练，我想说，虽然这不是完美的侧手翻，但它是一个很好的开始，尤其是对于初学者来说。它有正确的方向和节奏，这可能是最难的部分。
So good job, Creed. On a side note, I'm going to see Creed's show when he comes to Australia this year. Yay. I had to know. I texted Creed. I said, Creed, can you please tell me everything about this cartwheel?
所以干得好，克里德。顺便说一句，我今年要去澳大利亚看克里德的演出。耶。我必须知道。我给克里德发了短信。我说，克里德，你能把关于这个侧手翻的一切都告诉我吗？
He said he actually thought he could do a better cartwheel, and he wanted to try again, but they liked his first one. That sort of messed up cartwheel better. So he thinks this was the very first take, and he goes on to say, it was either one of our camera operators or the director that told me
他说他其实觉得自己能做一个更好的侧手翻，他想再试一次，但他们喜欢他的第一次。那种有点搞砸的侧手翻更好。所以他认为这是第一条，他接着说，是我们的摄影师或导演告诉我的
when Steve as Michael went to shake my hand, I was so pleased that I had done a cartwheel that I didn't even notice, and Steve thought it was even funnier. If you watch to the end of the scene, you can see me look at the camera operator and laugh because I didn't realize he had tried to shake my hand. I love that.
当史蒂夫（饰迈克尔）去跟我握手时，我为自己做了一个侧手翻而感到高兴，以至于我甚至没有注意到，史蒂夫觉得这更搞笑。如果你看到场景的最后，你可以看到我看着摄影师并笑了，因为我没有意识到他试图跟我握手。我很喜欢那个。
Isn't that so cute? That's great. Well, that was ultimate. I'm a big thank you as always to Randy Cordray for all his inside tidbits. Yes, and thank you, Creed Bratton, for always texting me about your funny scenes. And thank you guys for sending in your questions and comments.
是不是超级可爱？太棒了。好吧，就是这样。一如既往地非常感谢兰迪·科德雷分享的所有幕后花絮。是的，还要谢谢克里德·布拉顿，总是发短信告诉我你那些搞笑的场景。谢谢你们发来问题和评论。
Now, if you'll excuse me, I'm gonna go roller skate through Ear Wolf. I'll be videotaping that, so check out Office Ladies Pod Instagram. And next week, we're taking a break for Thanksgiving, but we will be back the week after with the seminar. See you then. I'm gonna move!
现在，如果你们不介意的话，我要去厄尔沃尔夫滑旱冰了。我会把它录下来，所以去看看 Office Ladies 的播客 Instagram 吧。下周，我们要休息一周过感恩节，但我们会在两周后带着研讨会回归。到时候见！我要搬家了！
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Ear Wolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
感谢收听 Office Ladies。Office Ladies 由 Ear Wolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。
For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to Stitcher Premium dot com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要收听 Office Ladies 的无广告版本，请访问 Stitcher Premium dot com。要免费试用一个月 Stitcher Premium，请使用代码 Office。这个节目目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。